MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
AMANDA SURYA: All right.
Well, welcome everybody to our
session on Content API for
Shopping office hour.
I am Amanda Surya.
I'm a Developer Relations
Manager for
Google Commerce products.
DANNY HERMES: And I'm Danny
Hermes, as you all may already
know, Developer Programs
Engineer on Google Shopping.
So thanks for joining
us today.
Amanda's got some questions that
we're going to be going
over covering some things that
people have been asking on the
forum and also some recent
developments in Google
Shopping as we go forward.
And if people have questions who
are viewing this remotely,
please feel free to add them
to our Moderator queue.
So--
AMANDA SURYA: All right.
So there's this question in our
forum recently about the
benefits of switching from
existing data feed
infrastructure to using the
content API for shopping.
Can you talk more about that?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
So first I wanted to say we
did a video last October.
And I mentioned this in
the forum as well.
And you can see the screenshare
of the YouTube
video here that I'm sharing
in the Hangout.
And we compare and contrast
feeds in the content API and
kind of cut out firm use cases
where you might actually be
more interested in
the content API.
And some of them were actually
expounded upon by Andrew from
Zazzle in the forum.
And he actually explained what
they used to do, what they do
now, what some of the downfalls
are, and how the
pros outweigh the cons.
So this actually speaks directly
to our best practices
because the best practices kind
of point to why you might
want to make the switch, or why
maybe you might not make
the switch, or why it might not
be necessary for you to
make the switch.
So I have it pulled up here,
the very first part of the
best practices page lists
when to use the
content API for shopping.
So--
AMANDA SURYA: So when
should we use it?
DANNY HERMES: Exactly.
So there are sort of
four use cases.
The first use case obviously
is when you want to be
programmatic, when you don't
actually want to have human
interaction or you don't
actually want to be uploading
something by hand.
AMANDA SURYA: If you
have a lot of--
DANNY HERMES: Right.
Or maybe you just have an
automated system and you want
it to stay automated, right?
Obviously, there are
ways to do this
already with feeds files.
But it requires manually
creating spreadsheets, or
comma-separated value sheets, or
some other column-formatted
feed, and then using FTP to
programmatically upload it.
And then, of course, there are
all these other issues.
Another nice-to-have feature,
which we certainly emphasize
in that video and we emphasize
here as well, is the fact that
you get immediate feedback back
from the API rather than
when you're using feeds.
Feedback is asynchronous.
And it comes in an email
summary, whereas feedback from
the API is immediate, on the
order of half a second.
And it is for every single
item in your particular
request that's being
given feedback.
And one of the main things that
Andrew emphasized and
that a lot of people making
the switch, the original
poster was asking-- they
said they had a
million and a half products.
Well, if you're sending feeds,
and even if you're sending
them once an hour and your feeds
are getting processed in
that hour, it's still an hour
out of date for some of the
products that were updated
at the very beginning.
So what they said at Zazzle
was they actually had some
merchants who were upset by the
infrequency of these updates.
And by using the content API,
they're actually able to get
these updates in almost
immediately rather than
waiting for the feed to get
processed and then the data to
get pushed back through.
And a final use case, which I'll
also touch on briefly,
was if you have multiple
subaccounts.
And going to the merchant center
and clicking through
all these subaccounts
is infeasible.
So even if you had multiple
people working on it, once you
exceed probably 10, 20
subaccounts, it's not really
very possible for human beings
to go in and make sure
particular changes are actually
as desired by the
client or the end user that
you're actually managing
product data for.
So the second part of this
document is actually the best
practices themselves, how to
actually go ahead and use the
content API.
And the very first one says
don't use the API as
you would use feeds.
So, obviously, this is sort of
like if you're on our side of
the fence, don't straddle the
fence type of recommendation.
But it actually shines some
light on why you might want to
make the switch.
in the feeds world, like I
previously mentioned, you have
to send your entire feed.
So you have to send the things
that don't change at all.
You have to send all
the new things.
You have to send the updates.
And you have to make sure
the things you're
deleting aren't in there.
Well, with the content API you
don't have to do that.
So all you have to do
with the content
API is send the changes.
And that's about all I'm going
to say about best practices.
Or actually, the fourth bullet
point in how to use the
content API for shopping is a
caveat that Andrew noted in
his response, which
is actually a
pretty important caveat.
So by default, products, whether
they're inserted via
feeds or via the content API,
they can't expire in
more than 30 days.
So the longest expiration you
can have for a product that
you insert or update
is 30 days.
And so if you're using the
content API, you're not
actually sending updates for
products that don't change.
Well, if for some reason part
of your inventory hasn't
changed in 30 days, on day 31 if
you don't send any updates,
that product will disappear
and eventually be garbage
collected and actually be out of
your inventory rather than
showing as expired in
your inventory.
So it's actually important when
you make the switch to
change this frame of mind from
I need to send all my product
data all the time to I need
to send my updates
whenever they happen.
And I also need to make sure
that my infrequently updating
products don't get obsoleted
via an expiration date.
So it was a great question.
And the poster also had another
question, which we're
actually going to
jump right to.
So--
AMANDA SURYA: Right.
So let's switch gear
a little bit.
There is another question,
different question about our
Java sample code, and what we
currently have, what we
currently provide, for a
developer who's using Java and
wants to use the content API for
shopping, and what's our
plan forward in terms
of resources.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
So people who look at our
Developer Resources in our
documentation will notice that
there's a Java Developer's
Guide, a .NET Developer's Guide,
a Python Developer's
Guide, and PHP Developer's
Guide.
And people who know all four
languages might look at the
Java Developer's Guide and
think, we don't like Java
developers.
But that's not the case.
We're a small team.
It's something we're aware of
that is a bit lagging behind
the other three.
But our sample is certainly a
workable starting point for
actual working Java code.
So the PHP library is sort
of a special case.
We manage our own small PHP
library just for shopping.
But for .NET and Python, there
are large gdata libraries.
So Python is
gdata-python-client.
And for .NET it's
google-gdata.
.NET must have gotten there
first for grabbing that name.
But for Java, we don't really
have any equivalent library
that we recommend
for merchants.
However, one exists.
Just like there's a
gdata-python-client, there's a
gdata-java-client.
And for actual gdata APIs, other
than the content API for
shopping that are implemented
there, the way the code is
implemented-- for example, the
way the HTTP requests are
formed and sent--
it uses an external
library that
obviously works with HTTP.
Similarly, for doing
authentication like client
login, OAuth, AuthSub, OAuth
1.0, or 2.0, that is, it uses
a JAR coming from a different
Google client library.
And this is something that the
original poster, Rich,
actually asked about.
So first I want to say that all
these dependencies in the
sample are actually consistent
with what the
gdata-java-client requires.
But the fact that we have sort
of hand-held data classes is
just a symptom of us
being a bit behind.
So we certainly are working
right now actively on getting
support into the library and
actually updating the section
in the Developer's
Guide about Java.
A few more things that I
want to say about this.
So first of all, the original
poster asked about the
difference between this
gdata library
and these new libraries.
And he quoted some statement in
the google-api-java-client
library about how Google
is updating to
discovery-based APIs.
And so I actually talk a bit
about all of this in a video
that I recorded.
We actually have a playlist of
all of our videos for content
API developers, and you
should see that
flashing across your screen.
This specific video where I talk
about Auth and OAuth 2.0
and some of these other
mechanisms is called Getting
Started with Google Shopping.
And there should be a short
link to the YouTube video
flashing across your screen
for that as well.
I actually go through the Auth
flow in Python around the
18-minute mark.
It takes about 22 minutes.
AMANDA SURYA: Right.
DANNY HERMES: So the difference
between gdata APIs
and these other APIs is just
sort of the newer Google APIs
are exactly that.
They're newer.
So gdata uses sort of
an older framework.
And we certainly don't have any
estimations on a timeline
or anything like that.
But for the time being,
the content
API is a gdata library.
So that is the target
for developers.
You shouldn't be targeting this
new library that exists,
but it's not actually intended
for gdata APIs.
So you should actually
be targeting
what's in the sample.
And finally, the last question
about why OAuth?
Why not client login?
Why not some of these
other ones?
So there are a few things
to say about that.
But most importantly, we
announced on April 20, as you
may be able to see in the screen
I'm sharing, that along
with some other older Google
APIs, the actual Auth APIs ,
other than OAuth 2.0, are
being deprecated.
So client login, AuthSub and
OAuth 1.0 are all being
deprecated.
And I believe April
20, 2015 is when
they're officially retired.
But between now and then, they
are to be considered
deprecated.
And I would highly recommend
against developing
with them in mind.
Rather, develop with
OAuth 2.0 in mind.
AMANDA SURYA: Right.
DANNY HERMES: And this is
something we certainly get
plenty of questions about.
And we're happy to go more in
depth about if people still
aren't understanding things.
AMANDA SURYA: Yeah.
And definitely feel free post
your additional questions
around OAuth 2.0 the
forum as well--
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
AMANDA SURYA: --if you have
concerns about that.
All right.
So another question that we
recently got is about
destination.
DANNY HERMES: Yep.
AMANDA SURYA: So in the spec,
there's three supported
destination values--
product search, product
ads, commerce search.
Can you talk more about that?
There are other valid
values as well.
What are those and how
can people use it?
DANNY HERMES: Right.
So this question from Thor--
love the name--
was a good question.
So he was asking, I'm seeing
some other values like
Shopping API and Affiliate
Network.
And I'm wondering why these
aren't in the documentation.
So these attributes are not
valid for every account.
So that's kind of why we don't
include them in our
documentation.
So some people who also have
used the search API for
shopping may be familiar with
the Google Affiliate Network.
And so product data, you can
actually make valid for the
destination Google Affiliate
Network if you're actually in
the Google Affiliate Network.
And by the same token, if you
elect, your product data can
also be consumed by all users
of the shopping API--
excuse me, the search
API for shopping.
And that's why the shopping API
destination is a possible
value as well.
But for the time being, products
ads, products search,
and commerce search are these
valid destinations.
So a bit more about how
to use destinations.
So Thor was having some issues
where he was getting errors
that he didn't really
understand why.
So if no destinations are sent,
then by default we say
you have to require at least one
destination as valid for
your product data.
And so the default value for
a required destination is
product search.
And the way required
destinations work is if your
product doesn't validate for
that destination, then your
response will be rejected.
And you'll get a failure.
So your product data will
never get uploaded or
inserted, whatever term
you're looking to use.
But whatever it is, it won't
end up in the database
corresponding to your merchant
center account.
So what Thor was doing was he
was asking for validate
destination for product search
with nothing else.
So this default value required
for product search was also
being inserted.
So the API doesn't allow you
to validate and require the
same destination.
So that's why his requests
were getting rejected.
And for those who aren't
familiar, what it means to
validate rather than
required--
so I mentioned this term
"validate" when I was talking
about required.
So are they the same?
Are they different?
Well, required will go ahead and
validate that destination.
And if it fails validation, it
will reject the request.
On the other hand, validate
destination will go ahead, and
it'll validate the destination
in question.
But rather than rejecting the
request if the actual product
data is valid for some other
destination, it won't get
inserted for the destination
that
you asked to be validated.
But you will get the errors back
for why it wasn't valid.
So it's a way for people who
maybe aren't as strict about a
particular destination, maybe
shopping API, for example.
But it allows for them to
actually attempt to get the
data put in there and then find
out why, for some reason,
the given product or set of
products weren't valid.
And then, of course, there's
this third value which Thor
didn't ask about but "excluded
destination." And that's
exactly what it sounds like.
You don't want your product
data surfacing in that
destination.
And it just won't
be validated.
It won't be inserted.
And then, there was sort of a
third question that Thor had.
And that was, given the move
from Google Product Search to
Google Shopping, what's going to
happen with product ads and
product search, and where
are we going with that?
So that's something I want
people to know that we're
thinking about.
But we don't have anything
to say at this time.
But it's certainly something
that we're aware of.
And I'm going to--
AMANDA SURYA: Speaking of
that, there's actually a
series of webinars that are
Google Shopping, Product
Marketing Managers, and
Partnership Teams put together.
And if you're wondering about
what it means, how to turn on
product listing apps on your
product listings, these series
or webinars, we highly recommend
you to review them.
It's a great resource to get
started at and also paint the
bigger picture in terms of
where Google Shopping is
moving forward.
And you can view the series
in the YouTube channel.
Or you can follow John
Venverloh, who is in the
partnership team.
And he basically, on his G+
page, lists all the series of
webinars that he and
his team has done.
And it's a great resource,
again, for some of you who
want to get a better
understanding of the overall
picture and interim materials
to Google Shopping.
DANNY HERMES: Yep.
And we'll be posting some links
in that YouTube video
after the fact.
So if you're actually watching
the YouTube video after the
fact, the link should be
in the description.
We'll link to John's page and
the specific posts that he has
linked as well as to the channel
where you can find
some of these videos.
AMANDA SURYA: All right.
So those are pretty much
the questions that
we've seen in the forum.
And there are no questions
in the Google Moderator.
So I think we're off
the hook here.
DANNY HERMES: All righty.
AMANDA SURYA: And for those of
you listening in, thank you
for joining us.
And if you want to learn more
about the content API for
shopping as well as our other
commerce APIs, visit
developers.google.com/commerce
and all the information and
documentation should be there.
And we're doing this biweekly,
so hope to
see you in two weeks.
DANNY HERMES: How many
days are in August?
30 or 31?
AMANDA SURYA: 31?
DANNY HERMES: I think
there's 31.
So September 13th is
14 days from now.
All righty.
Thanks, everyone.
AMANDA SURYA: All right.
DANNY HERMES: And
have a nice day.
AMANDA SURYA: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]